bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video sono con mike scioscia punto
con sé e per sé il re pisodio di fa smo
copia the vast ma proprio che il disco
dello schermo del telefono totalmente
bello quindi preparate buona visione
nel momento allora genio cosa che ci ha
scritto che l'acqua sporca vedi sempre
un altra roba se vi attacca be spegnete
la torta si inizierà a peggiorare la
torcia spegnetela così questa cosa la so
di per certo che ho visto gente morire
perché si è permesso
cosa che non dobbiamo fare chiamarlo per
nome quindi va bene non so se questa è
la casa di jennifer thompson però vai
andare in casa ballate che serve bene
ragazzi anni per se ci 6 de col segno
ecco è cascato qualcosa ma è così non fa
paura era che a mia nonna
comunque se siamo lontani da lontani da
lontanissimo a parlare con il conosciuto
a chi conviene
io sono come mai qualcuno allora vedono
i camion che chi ha acceso la mia che
mario non lo so non io
la gara ca fermi fermi qua c'è un calo
qua c'è un calo di temperatura
astronomico qua qua sul fornello c'è un
calo di temperatura astronomico qua c'è
tra i tre gradi celsius qua ma poiché
arredamento anche perché c'è delle
tartine attaccate al soffitto che premia
quelle della carta moschicida oltre a
potrebbe essere quello poi c'è però
dello spettro nella casa bravo e ragazzi
ragazzine che qui e qui e qui rilevo
attività paranormali
allora per lo sento sentite sentite da
questo qua e qua qua un cadavere che è
morto è lo senti come le smesso di
battere il cuore è molto bassa ragazzi
in quel punto lì è veramente bassa
proprio si sta qualora provava a
chiamarlo è arrivato a trovarlo
aspettato che va bene allora facciamo
così io direi di fare questo brutto il
segnalatore li buttiamo il quaderno a
terra e lasciamo solo favi a parlare col
fantasma
va bene grazie per questo compito
ingrato ma il fantasma sì ma il fantasma
si chiamava jennifer thompson jennifer
thompson abbiamo creato dai rockets che
è successo che cosa parla come l'ar
appoggiato le luci e di caratura ma
l'appetito con il cazzo di thomson ma
per caso nome è jennifer thompson o
senza della presenza jennifer thompson
dove sei
jennifer mostrati oddio che casino staff
aqua jennifer thompson dove sei mostrati
a noi
[Musica]
oddio santo benedetto le luci sentono
ragazzi ciao davanti a prima porta a
porta sono fatti ecco adesso non c'è il
primo adesso non c'è più è appena andata
via ragazzi che prestavano recata va su
youtube l'ho vista jennifer thompson
mori thompson jenny più di nascondi e
più tele premi per forza così che va a
evocato un fantasma grazie del taccuino
per terra
jennifer johnson g compiti
quindi per tutti non fanno i compiti
grazie ragazzi oddio oddio rai che c'è
qualcosa non vedo eccola eccola la
fotografa è stato fatto che la parte
l'ho fatto l'ho fotografata regalo
fotografata cielo c'era compresa
jennifer thompson tuo fotografato e fai
schifo
l'ho fotografata lega ce l'ho in video
cioè fotocamera quindi qualcosa verrà
sta cosa era quasta vacua sa fare cose
con tagliere successo ma c'è una male
qualcosa davanti a dio dio sta morendo
ragazzi sono molto ma come sono morto
jennifer thompson tu madre morta
maledetta è morto jennifer thompson
marco disputate io mi sento è vi seguo
quindi fatto in tutto come volevamo sono
ok non mi posso solo parlamento il piano
il piano sto scusando con e piane o raga
incredibile mai a roma è raga c'è stavo
solo io e cucina ma non è giusto
io rimango con michael jennifer thompson
aliper tombino l'evento le porte per me
le porte sono tutte chiuse sono aperte
rega ma loro non è chiusa aiutami le
vedo perche dio sa qual è quella qua è
morto
friendly offre di lucas mai che sono
morto lì per terra che prendi una
bambina di correre non è mica mi sono
spaventato e stato bellissimo si sono
accasati nelle mutande sempre più vicino
dopo bellissimo visto ma che correva di
là ma guardate come sono molto male poi
con la testa dentro il comodino ma cosa
mi va neanche con la testa fuori dentro
la credenza pozzato proprio piazzarla
raga dovete risponde al telefono in giro
o sta arrivando il toro sta tornando e
quale che sta tornando morì ammazzato
tutti i legali sono morti eccola equa
regata eccola qua in cucina e ragazzo
ammazzato tutti quasi e morto steve era
step quello stesso mi senti
ma siete ora io posso vedere step che
qua ecco eccola qua regalo occhio equa
la vedo lei è bellissima che c'è il
fantasma che gli paradosso e loro sono
così c'è degli ubriachi scappate basta
stare in casa siamo molti 2 andate via
che prove avete siamo morti un cadavere
è morto scappate scappate dio che brutta
scena stava fa con mike rigg scappate
scappata andatevene via andatevene
andate ne sta andando
c'è il segnale che sta solo sta
esplodendo via via io so se mi potete
sentire ma siamo morti noi chi se ne
frega delle steli luce chiama
l'ambulanza va al 118 chiama qualcuno
che se chi se ne frega le sveglie festa
al 4 per cento di sanità di squadra
stava è successo abbiamo basten
no no no sul partito selezionarla gigi
golkar a matita caso no ci hanno dato
dei soldi lo stesso stereo risino la
pagherà 60 vero male fantasma era un
circolazione 45 ha fatte fotografica in
fotografia ma da 12 a 10 euro a
fotografare un fantasma ma va a cagare
dai ragazzi questa è la l'episodio di
omofobia di oggi con mike step ovvero vi
sia piaciuto siamo una squadra
incredibile per caso che sono scopato
lasciate dai cavi di iscrivetevi al
canale farli sopra di commenti se volete
bisogno di farlo favia e tattiche robe
tanto pian piano ma mettiamo il livello
quindi aumenta la difficoltà ma nel
mentre scrivete roma ha ricordato siamo
quasi a 6 milioni quindi magari
iscrivetevi a questo di canale
[Musica]